大変裏投げ始め皆さん同様の単に好きですか
僕は間違いなくこちらコカコーラです後加工等でいろんな者に貸してペイントがペット
ボトルかかんとかあるんですけども僕
感が一番好きなんですがこの考えがどれだけだろうかな
twitter で調べたんですけども結構500ml 缶コカコーラ支援者の方が
多くて
ブレスかペットボトルとかピンク積み重ねることができないんですけどブーブー感じで
めっちゃ綺麗に積み重ねられることができるんですよ明けで今回はうーさーああヌー本
ぐらいの空港等の母住民ヌー全部コカコーラティ
[音楽]
単純単純だけどもびっくりしますよほんとで言える中全部コーラじゃないんですけども
扉の入り口だけをコーラの壁作れば大手がどうなってるかわかんないんですってくださ
飲みたい人からするとひょっとちゃんなんか全部コーナーじゃないかと思って単純だ
けども一瞬濃度止まるんじゃないかと思いますよさすぐ家の扉にコーラおいていこうと
思いますねらーっと言うけど
もどってベージュの国コーラ準備しましたこんだけあれば多分全部いけると思いますよ
早速
電気においていきました
ちなんで終わったんですけど全然足りそうな気がしますねいつ200本近くが準備して
ありますやまず考え中んいっしょ好きじゃないですかねぇ
いや女ちょっと楽しいものが統一されてるの見ると結構するんだよね上手なこんなに
同じ向きで同じ物を置けるとはから本当に倒れないことを願っております本当に本当に
不利じゃない本当に倒れたしかね今回分かります
絵がアレなんですよねほんとサイズの高額オーラ全然売ってなかったせよどこ行っても
ドンキにあった後セブンイレブンの一部しか置いてないです受けな人多いんでちょっと
色んな面でおいた方がいいってことでペットことでリヤせよ
4する番目やっぱしっかりしてるとか折れるって言えないがこのままた不調やまで行け
そうですね
[音楽]
おやおや日
ただいたいって大丈夫だよねすごい
バレてそんなねっ
ねえんだすごい不安になってきたんですけど大丈夫だよねほんとに倒れないで
者だよ
[音楽]
ブーバーさあ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーバーねほんとれ本当ねだねこれじゃあねっ
ん
本当にあるさんといっしょ他の子に迷惑受けるだけダメよ
うちら全員でチーム国防ラン何だからね誰一人欠けたため分かった
[音楽]
待っててったにご負担になりました
またねバイバイにはやはりそれはやばいそれやばいそれはやばいやばいそれがやば
すぎるって味の冠を付けこんなところでだめだよなんて3万円に感謝まあいいやばいや
それはダメか
誰なのかあっ日急にどうしたん
あ急にどうしたなにがあったので9人中ね今まであんなに嘲笑勝つため名前何かあった
んだよってお前もダメか誰だよ
ダメちょっとこっちの子が皆さんやばいことなってきたなんでだろうをずっと
そうな日母はな人生いやーこれやばいな本当に他の人に迷惑かけちゃダメですからね
ok っす
やばいもう怖くなってきたを前に倒れるのようなんでこの壁の手前にちょっとだけ
コーラ置いておきます
もうこれで方として二重構造みたいなって言うネタをれるリスクを管理軽減されたと
思います
お前さんまずいよ大丈夫よしいけるのは無理だよ無理だったら隣の人により吹かれ自分
で全部か外交もとススメだわかったな
[音楽]
待ってまあまあて駄目だ
えっ
方私はわかりました自分のすべきことを食べなんで二列で作るものになかったんですよ
ホットみんなの頭からの結束が必要的なさん熱で壁を作っていこうと思いますこれだと
倒れない間違えたもう同じ過ちは
繰り返さないんだぞ
be sure
t
に向けこれの壁完成しました
まぁ結局いろいろ試行錯誤したんだけどもうものを詰めるのが一番良かったですから
相当難しかったスネカンって1回落としたりすると変形するんでそれで結構ねーじゃ
なかったというわけ
家のドアを開けた瞬間目の前がコーラの瓶だったら人はどういう反応するのでしょうか
一緒に家ん中10向こうラーって絶対思うと思うんです良ければ
me
うん
まくるー
クエ
あああああん
ねええええ
[音楽]
ん
パーカーコーラファーん
ああああああ
ん
でしっの